jouer vu que le coup
[Musique]
les chansons de carmen campagne un bon
chocolat chaud ou encore la moustache à
papa sont entrés au panthéon de la
musique pour enfants
je m'appelle et je suis
carmen est né le 8 septembre 1959 à
willows bolt en saskatchewan
dans les années 70 sa famille crée le
groupe folle avoine
[Musique]
un premier album signé carmen campagne
une voie pour les enfants sort en 1990
c'est le succès notamment grâce au titre
bien connu un bon chocolat chaud
carmen devient la diva des petits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'autres albums suivront dont la vache
en alaska et le téléphone au milieu des
années 2000
l'artiste retourne dans l'ouest en 2009
on peut la voir dans l'émission carmen à
la campagne je pense que aussi
l'expérience
[Musique]
trois ans plus tard elle sort un nouvel
album et un dvd nommé sur la ferme de
grand père j'ai grandi sur une ferme
alors pour moi ça évoque de bons
souvenirs d'enfant auteure compositrice
et interprète carmen campagne est adoré
par les tout-petits en 2013
elle devient membre de l'ordre du canada
il adorait la musique qui son dernier
album de chansons compères guéri sort en
2014 carmen campagne aura bercé des
générations de francophones j'avais une
bonne centaine fois facile ici samuel
rancourt radio canada à winnipeg